good afternoon
well good afternoon everybody happy
Friday
okay
you good
I want to start by saying a word about
the death of Tyree Nichols last night
the president extended condolences to
the family of Tyree Nichols and to the
entire Memphis community and he
addressed the pain this is causing
Across America as once again we grapple
with the fact that fatal encounters with
law enforcement are disparately
impacting brown and black people as the
Department of Justice conducts a full
investigation and state authorities
continue their work the president has
joined tyree's family in calling for
protests to remain peaceful
last year the president called on
Congress to send the George Floyd
Justice and policing act to his desk
when they didn't he signed an executive
order that included stricter use of four
standards and accountability Provisions
for federal law enforcement as well as
measures to strengthen accountability at
the state and local level today we all
must recommit ourselves
to the critical work that must be done
to advance meaningful reforms the
president continues to believe that in
order to deliver real change we must
have accountability when Law Enforcement
Officers violate their Oaths and we need
to build lasting trust between law
enforcement the vast majority of whom
wear the badge honorably
and the communities they are sworn to
serve and to protect
tyree's death is a painful reminder that
we must do more to ensure that our
Criminal Justice System lives up to the
promise of fair and impartial Justice
equal treatment and dignity for all
today is international Holocaust
Remembrance Day when we pause to more
than 6 million Jews who were brutally
murdered during the Holocaust
and to grieve the many other ethnic
minorities people with disabilities
lgbtqi plus individuals and political
dissidents who were also killed during
this dark chapter in history
We join together in saying never again
and yet across the country we see
swastikas on cars anti-semitic banners
on Bridges verbal and physical attacks
against Jewish businesses and Jewish
Americans even Holocaust denialism
it's vile we must affirm over and over
that hate has no Safe Harbor in America
today second gentleman of the United
States Douglas mhoff participated in a
commemorative
commemoration ceremony at the Auschwitz
birkenau concentration camp in Poland
and will visit Berlin Germany in the
coming days to coordinate International
efforts to combat anti-Semitism this
work continues here at home last year we
held a historic White House Summit on
combating hate-fueled violence the
president appointed the first Ambassador
level special Envoy to Monitor and
combat anti-semitism
and we are developing a national
strategy to fight anti-semitism
we've secured the largest increase in
funding ever for the physical security
of non-profits including synagogues and
Jewish community centers as our work
continues we will continue to honor and
remember the millions who were murdered
in the Holocaust
let me start with two developments that
speak to the president's top priority
the safe the safety of American people
President Biden is relentlessly
committed to protecting Americans from
threats to to their safety and he's
equally committed to ensuring Justice
and accountability to those who threaten
American lives on Wednesday evening as
you all saw and have been reporting
acting on orders from from the president
the U.S military conducted a successful
Over the Horizon counter-terrorism
operation in Northern Somalia that
resulted in the death of Bilal al-sodani
a leader and enabler for Isis Global
Network as well as approximately 10
additional Isis operatives Sudanese
activities provided funding to sustain
the deadly capabilities of Isis
Affiliates globally including the Isis
Coruscant branch in Afghanistan one of
Isis most lethal branches Sudanese
removal Builds on this administration's
remarkable successes in eliminating the
global leaders of Isis and of al-Qaeda
also this week doj has taken custody of
rafat amarav who was part of a murder
for higher operation targeting an
iranian-american critic of the Iranian
government in the United States as doj
explained amarav was was was a resident
in Iran when this plot developed but
that did not prevent him from now facing
American Justice the government of Iran
continues to plot the murder of
dissidents in American citizens
including current and former U.S
officials President Biden has directed
use of all elements of National Power to
expose and disrupt these plots and to
pursue those responsible
today marks a moment of emphasis to
emphasize yet again our Relentless
commitment to protecting Americans to
holding accountable those who threaten
American lives and here's a bit on what
you can expect from the president in the
in the week ahead today the president
will head to Camp David on Sunday he
will travel to Wilmington Delaware on
Monday the president will travel to
Baltimore Maryland the president will
discuss how bipartisan infrastructure
law funding will replace the 150 year
old Baltimore and Potomac tunnel to
address the largest bottleneck for
commuters on the Northeast Corridor
between Washington DC and New Jersey the
president will be joined by Department
of Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge on Thursday the president
will travel to New York
uh New York and uh the president will
discuss how bipartisan infrastructure
law funding for the Hudson River tunnel
project will improve reliability for the
200 000 passenger trips per weekday on
Amtrak and New Jersey Transit on
Thursday morning the president will
attend the National Prayer Breakfast on
Capitol Hill in the afternoon the
president will deliver remarks
to the to Mark the 30th anniversary of
the Family and Medical Leave Act in the
East room and on Friday
the president and the vice president
will travel to Philadelphia Pennsylvania
they will discuss the progress we have
made and their work implementing the by
the Biden Harris economic agenda that
continues to deliver results for the
American people after the president will
travel to Wilmington Delaware where he
will remain over the weekend one final
thing and all of you have seen our
statement and the present statement on
this and our and you guys have reported
but I wanted to um to just speak to the
president's announcement today that
white house chief of staff Ron Clane
will be departing in the coming weeks
and Jeff Zions will succeed him as Chief
of Staff you you all have the statement
and you know how much Ron has been a big
part of many so many historical things
we have accomplished the president has
been able to accomplish over these first
two years of his administration but I
wanted to zero in on one important piece
that we believe matters
the president said and I quote and while
we have accomplished an extraordinary
amount the real Mark of Ron's success is
that he beloved he is beloved by the
team he leads here at the White House
they're going to miss him just as much
as I will if he would just indulge me
for a second because I do again think
this is incredibly important in another
point of personal privilege as I did
earlier this week because you know I am
a proud claniac as I mentioned here a
couple days ago which is real just look
it up
I just wanted to share a moment that I
think perfectly encapsulates how much
Ron means to everyone here
we have a daily senior staff Call every
single morning
it's where we run through what's
happening here and normally each
department heads uh gives an update on
what's going on for them and their teams
for that day but today was a little
different
Ron started off by tearfully telling the
team how proud he was to serve with them
and how he was even prouder to what we
accomplished together over the last two
years and then each person went around
telling their own favorite Ron story
there were a lot of tears and uh even
but even more more love on the call
office of legislative affairs director
Luisa Terrell told a story of how she
got Ron a rock during a tough period
because he is a rock here
Homeland Security advisor Liz Sherwood
Randall remnants about how she had Ron
she had known Ron since they were kids
who went to work for Joe Biden in 1986
very long time ago
domestic policy advisor Susan Rice
called Ron the best Chief of Staff she's
ever worked for
which senior advisor John podesta then
concurred with with after he left as you
know John fodesta was also a chief of
staff here at some point
IGA director Julie Rodriguez noted how
consequential the last two years have
been under Ron's leadership as we passed
some of the boldest policies that are
improving the lives of Americans every
day and counselor to the President Steve
roschetti close it out with I quote you
always paid attention to the little
things that matter to people
more than anything you've made this
group feel like more than just
colleagues but really like a family and
I will add just for me personally
one of the things that I love about Ron
is that he sees you when no one else
sees you and when he does see you he
lifts you up and that is what what is
the definition of a leader is and that
is Ron claim and with that I'll say Ron
will always be part of the family we are
also also very much looking forward to
have have someone like Jeff lead this
team he is someone who many of us know
very well and understands how to get big
things done if you've seen his resume
you would totally understand that he's
tackled the toughest issues in
government all throughout his career
from fixinghealthcare.gov to Leading our
historic coveted response he led the
National Economic Council during Obama
Biden
Administration and shares the
president's focus on strengthening our
economy and growing it from the ma the
bottom up and middle out he led our
administration's transition into office
under incredibly trying circumstances
you all were there and watched us trying
to get our get the administration
together at that time and thanks to Jeff
we had a historically diverse team in
place on day one ready to work now in
year three a big task ahead is ensuring
the historic laws we pass are
implemented efficiently and fairly no
person no better person to do that than
Jeff Zions and may I also add there is
no better or Kinder human being we are
also all waiting to see the bagel
Wednesdays I think you all have heard us
talk about this we hope that it makes
this triumphant return and next week the
White House will host an official
transition event to thank Ron for his
tireless work and officially welcomed
Jeff back to the White House in this
role thank you for indulging me I really
appreciate this opportunity to do that
and with that Darlene you want to kick
us off sure thank you uh one follow on
chief of staff and one follow on Tyree
Nichols uh as you know they're separate
videos today that are being released one
on the attack on former speaker Pelosi's
husband the other on the beating of
Tyree Nichols can you say whether the
president has any interest in watching
or seeing either of those videos
particularly the Memphis one since you
mentioned police reform in their opening
so as I mentioned the president sent his
heartfelt condolences to Tyree Tyree
Nichols family yesterday he and the
first lady and he's going to be uh
regularly briefed as he has been he's
going to be monitoring the situation I
you know as as
the case continues to develop clearly
he'll be
um he'll be keeping a close eye I don't
have anything further to read out on
that piece on the video obviously the
video is not out yet
um but uh again he'll be regularly
updated as far as Paul Pelosi I have not
seen the video yet I know that that was
just released and I know many many of
the cable news outlets have been showing
the video to this morning I haven't had
a chance to check in with him or to ask
him but I think you don't even need a
video to know how horrific and
unconscionable the attack of Paul pools
he was and to be very honest it's a
miracle that Paul was not more seriously
injured and we are grateful that he is
on his way and continues to to recover
the president has always been clear and
continues to to be clear to condemn any
sort of political violence there is no
place for it here in our country and
he's going to always believe that it
asks for people to come together
Republicans Democrats it doesn't matter
which party you're in to condemn the
political violence and violent rhetoric
that we have seen over the years and
with the chief of staff news today
that position is one of the more
powerful ones in Washington that has
never been held by someone who is not
white and male with the president commit
to choosing a chief of staff who is not
white and male if Jeb signs were to
leave before the end of the president's
term here's what I say I'll say to this
I'm certainly not going to get ahead of
the president that is not something that
I can do from here but look and I kind
of set it at the top the Biden Harris
Administration is the most diverse in
history that is a fact and we expect to
uh we expect this trend to continue the
cabinet is majority people of color for
the first time in history the cabinet is
majority female for the first time in
history the majority of white house
senior staff identify as female 40 of
White House senior staff identify as
part of racially diverse communities a
record six assistance to the president
are openly lgbtq and also of our if you
think about of our three thousand about
three thousand appointees 58 female 51
percent people of color six percent
disabled 31 first generation Americans
17 uh first generation College grads and
14 uh when they say 17 first generation
College grads if we're about to add that
percent and 14 lgbtq and I think that
matters this is a this is a this is a
record that the president is truly proud
of and I think not just the president
all of us here who are members of his
team
thanks Karina I know there's been
coordination on the law enforcement
level but have there been uh any
conversations you can tell us about
between the White House and state
officials or Governors about how to
handle the possibility of unrest this
weekend so a couple of things there I
just want to reiterate what the family
uh what the family and the president
have called for which is uh peaceful
peaceful protest protest for people to
please protest peacefully that is
something that the president will
continue to call on and he joined as I
just mentioned his family the White
House has been in coordination with the
relevant agencies to ensure they prepare
if protests become violent
this coordination is standard practice
and in keeping with what the
administration has done in other
instances including the anticipation as
you all know for the dab decision the
the trucker Convoy protest and election
day those are three examples that I can
share with you at this moment
Administration officials have been and
will continue to be in touch with state
and local officials on the ground as as
we watch the next few hours develop has
the president spoken with the Nichols
family directly or does he plan to uh
obviously when a tragedy happens like
this the president uh always always
wants to extend personally his heartfelt
condolences to the family I don't have a
call to read out or call schedule at
this time but again I would I would
refer you to the statement yesterday but
our hearts are with Tyree Nichols family
and the Memphis Community as well and
then can you confirm a report by our
friends at Reuters that Elon Musk met
with Mitchell Andrew the infrastructure
coordinator here at the White House
today about electric vehicles what were
they talking about I know the White
House hasn't always had the uh the the
nicest things to say about Tesla and its
uh its labor friends so I can I can
confirm that uh that uh Mitch Landrieu
and also John podesta met with Elon Musk
to discuss electrification and how the
bipartisan infrastructure line the
inflation reduction act can advance EVs
and the increase the electrifications
more broadly so that meeting did happen
today and so for sure I can I can
confirm that to all of you mark a
turning up the page of the relationship
between this White House in Elon Musk
um I will say that I think the the
Outreach and the meeting says a lot of
how important the president thinks the
bipartisan infrastructure legislation is
and how the inflation reduction Act is
especially as we it relates to EVs and
his commitment and so I will leave it
there but I think it's important that
his team his senior members of his team
had a meeting with Elon Musk today to do
just that
thanks I'm on police reform does the
president regret not making it more of a
top priority in his work with Congress
over these last two years you mentioned
how he called on Congress to pass the
George Floyd act but it didn't seem like
one of his
um big priority legislative pushes you
know I I have to say I disagree one of
the things that the president said when
he walked in into the administration the
multiple crises that we've had to deal
with that the country was dealing with
at the time as obviously there was covid
there was uh the economy because of
kovid there was climate change and the
other one was dealing with the racial
unrest that we had seen across the
country that we've all went through and
many of you spoke to and he took action
when Congress was not able to get the
joy Floyd policing act done he took
action as I just laid out he took action
by doing an executive taking executive
ashing and doing everything that he
could from with the tools that he had so
he did take it very seriously and he's
going to continue to be very vocal he's
made speeches about this over the past
couple of years and and he's talked to
Congress and as has has asked Congress
to uh to take action he
has spoken to uh many times to uh the um
the leaders in Congress who put forth
like Cory Booker and others who put
forth that piece of legislation and
we'll our team will continue to have
those conversation but again by taking
executive action I think showed and we
believe showed the president's
seriousness on this
one more topic just went outside any
response to meta reinstating former
president Trump's accounts on Facebook
and Instagram so look we are don't we're
not going to comment on an individual
um Twitter account or or
um social media accounts from here that
is the responsibility that is something
that the independent clearly platforms
decide on and uh you know we rely on the
uh on the platforms that private company
to make sure that uh that uh that their
platform is not used to incite violence
and so that is something that we will
continue to to call on but we're not
going to comment on individual uh
individual people
um on uh Kyrie Nichols um the
negotiations that happened last year
um in the Senate obviously paused
um does the president want to see um
those resume on the George Floyd uh
policing well I think as you saw in his
statement the pro the president was very
clear we need to deliver a change we
must have accountability when Law
Enforcement Officers violate their olds
and we need to build a long lasting
trust between law enforcement and the
vast majority of who who wear the badge
of honor in an honorary way an honorable
way I should say and the communities
that they swear they are sworn to
protect and to serve and so we need he
believes we need to continue to do to
move towards uh that type of change and
he's going to continue to call on
Congress to come together and to deal
with a true a real issue I mean again we
are having the same conversation talking
about the same thing uh brutality a
death of a young man
that we shouldn't be doing we shouldn't
be reliving this type of hurt and pain
and and having to you know reach out to
the families and a community and saying
that we're with them in this time this
should not be where we are today but
specifically those Senate talks that
were happening between Cory Booker and
Tim Scott and others is that something
that needs to be restarted at this point
I mean I'll say this we we think
Congress should should act and take
action and put legislation to the full
into the floor that deals with this in a
real in a real way and that is going to
be up to Congress on what that looks
like and what that uh ultimately
ultimately materializes to be but again
the president's going to call on them
and and he's committed to really seeing
being part of the crucial work that to
advance meaningful reform and is there
any specific provision in that bill or
in any other bill that would prevent the
kind of death
we saw here look I mean if you look at
the joy Floyd policing act which is
something that the president supported
last year there were some real important
components Provisions in that act that
we thought would start the process of
being bringing forward meaningful change
as the president is going to continue to
call for but again we're going to work
with Congress we're going to continue to
call on Congress to really move
something forward that's going to deal
with an issue that has been
disproportionately really affecting the
brown and black community
hey screen um the legislative issues
aside I think the president spoke
publicly about what seemed to be a
genuine Bond he had formed with George
Floyd's family and I was wondering if
you could talk about just from a
personal side of things for him how much
that has informed or uh maybe had an
impact on how he processes or sees
things like what it appears we're about
to be done about this
you know this Phil I think you covered
you've you've covered the president or
certainly watched the president the last
couple of years especially during that
time as his relationship with the George
Floyd family developed and they've met
many times and they've spoken many times
and uh you know I I cannot imagine how
conversations like that don't have an
effect on someone right when you see
when you see a family going through so
much pain and that pain being captured
on video for all the world to see
so yeah I think it's had an impact on
all of us here it's had an impact on
many across across the country across
the globe and yeah I think he takes this
very seriously he takes he sees what is
going on he hears the stories he talks
to the families and he feels that it's
important it's important to to make sure
that these families that go through this
get Swift and full and transparent
answers and investigation to the death
of their loved ones don't want to get
too far into it because as you know the
doj is looking into this as also the
local authorities and there's going to
be a trial so I don't want to get too
far into this particular case but as you
asked me about the George Floyd family
yeah I think it's uh I think it affected
all of us you know meeting them and
listening to their story and what
they've had the pain that they are still
going through
um
you've got this a little bit and save it
but in terms of his call for uh protest
non-violence is he confident that it
feels like that's where things are going
at this moment in time and how will he
ensure that that message continues I
guess to to be durable over the course
the next couple days yeah look he's
gonna he called on he called for a
peaceful protest he joined the family I
think I think people should listen to
the family
as they call for peaceful protest as
well and I think that's really important
and we understand we understand the
outrage people have currently and how
hurt and painful this is but we're going
to continue to say violence but violence
is unacceptable and so uh you know I
just laid out a moment ago of what we
are trying to do here meeting the
president has met with the agencies his
administration has been very much in
touch with local and state officials to
do everything that we can to prevent
that but again the president has always
been very clear when it comes to uh when
it comes to violence not being the
answer and making sure that when we
protest it's when people protest it's
peaceful
I just want to clarify the FBI director
has said he has seen the videos of Tyree
Nichols uh said he was appalled has uh
the president been briefed about the
contents of the video or has he seen the
video footage himself already I can tell
you the president has not uh he's been
brief but he is not has not seen the
video
so I can confirm that and uh but look he
has been briefed on what occurred and
what he knows what what he's able to uh
to be briefed on from his team but he
has not seen the video was it the FBI or
was it I don't have a specific clearly
senior Administration officials have I
don't have the specific name or person
to lay out for you on a separate topic
regarding the debt ceiling uh Senator
Joe manchin says in his recent private
meeting with speaker McCarthy the
McCarthy study is quote no intention on
touching Medicare or Social Security
what is the White House reaction to
hearing that
do you agree uh with with what the
senator is saying there we'll look for
for months and months and months now uh
and many of you have reported this they
have been saying that they are going to
they're planning to cut Social Security
and Medicare this is what Republicans
have been saying for months for months
and uh and you know I have a few a few
reporting from from some of your
colleagues from your esteemed colleagues
uh just the other day the Washington
Post headline
from is is quote house Gopi Social
Security Medicare and spending ballot uh
battle end quote on or Reuters earlier
in January Republican house
conservatives threatened debt limit
default to cut Social programs that has
been consistent with what House
Republicans have been saying they want
to uh you know uh hold hostage uh the
the debt uh so that uh they want to
default on it so that they can cut
Social Security so that they can cut
Medicare Medicare and let's not forget
these are programs that the Americans
people have paid into we're talking
about veterans and seniors senior
citizens here and uh here's another one
for example here's a Fox news headline
from less than a month ago before
election day Republicans are I using
debt limit hike to overhaul entitlement
programs if trust if entrusted with
majority
and this is what we have seen for months
and months and months this is what they
have been saying for months and months
and months it doesn't seem like
McCarthy's signaling he's not going to
be touching them I I I understand the
question but I'm telling you what his
Republican conference has been saying
for some time now and they continue to
say that I just read an article from
earlier this week that said that is what
they want to do and here's the thing you
know as you talk about uh you know the
debt ceiling as we talk of how about
this this conversation that we've been
having for weeks about their
responsibility and what they should be
doing Congress in a both Republicans and
Democrats in a bipartisan way to deal
with this issue that's been dealt with
78 times since 1960. we haven't seen a
plan from Republicans what's their plan
we know that what they want to cut but
what's their plan
and so uh you know it's been very clear
to us what they want to do and uh and
it's been very clear all through this
week as well
Hope on that please
um if the Republicans in the house do
present a plan uh for conditions for
what they would raise uh the debt limit
under uh will you start negotiations
with them on that plan what would be the
point of them presenting you with a list
of Demands well what I'm saying is they
want to cut cut but they are they're
just saying this rhetoric that's
incredibly dangerous that is very
dangerous to our full the full credit uh
and of of our of our country right you
think about what you think about the
debt steel you think about the debt
limit it is something it is we're
talking about debt that has been racked
up by Congress right but we continue to
say we are not this should be done when
it comes to the debt limit the debt
ceiling it should be done without
condition that doesn't change anything
I'm just laying out how they're
proceeding here it's such an a reckless
way uh and so we're just calling that
out but it doesn't change where we stand
it doesn't change the fact that we are
not going to negotiate here this is
something that should be dealt with like
it has been many many times before in
the last Administration three times
three times Kevin McCarthy other other
uh House Republicans voted for it under
the last Administration and and again
this is a bipartisan way that it's been
done in the past and it should be done
this way again this year
NHS the president would delay his
departure to Camp David tonight in order
to see the video release when it's
scheduled and because Camp David is one
of the places where it's actually
difficult for the president to
immediately address the nation if there
were to be a concern do you expect that
he may want to say something uh in a in
a live way he's already spoken through
you and he's spoken on paper but do you
anticipate that this is the kind of
circumstance where he'd want to
emphasize that by appearing on camera so
I don't have any changes uh for you on
his uh uh on his schedule today I will
say like you just mentioned you heard
from him last night in clear terms and
expressing his condolences to the family
and the people of Memphis and he's going
to continue to call for Meaningful
reforms he said that last night and he
said that many times before and he's
going to continue to call for a protest
to remain peaceful I just don't have
anything to share at this time on on his
schedule is there anything you can share
about his plans for Camp David since
he's doing Camp David and Wilmington
this weekend are there any meetings that
are scheduled at Camp David or things
that are government related this weekend
so he tends to have internal internal
meetings as you all know with his with
his team don't have anything to read out
as well at this time but that is
something that he often does whether
it's virtually or in person to keep to
keep abreast especially with the next
couple of hours to certainly continue to
be briefed on the situation in Memphis
and we're running out of January and you
had told us that we'd have the physical
and the information about the
president's physical any update on
whether that might slide into February
now I don't have any updates on that at
this time look we want to this is
something that we're committed to doing
as I've said we've did it back in 2021
in a very transparent way and I shared
the doctor's memo to all of you for you
all to review and it was very extensive
it was again in a transparent fashion
and so we're committed to doing that I
just don't have any updates at this time
Haiti has gone through another tough
week I know your question earlier this
week but
um we heard Helen lalim at the U.N
security Council talk about it yesterday
it was the police officers who paralyzed
because there were officers that
horribly been killed over there any
progress because people are begging for
the United States and Canada again
involved in a respected International
force on the ground any progress in the
discussion so as you know as you just
mentioned together the U.S and Canada
have taken action to provide assistance
to the people of Haiti while also
holding those causing this crisis
accountable including through sanctions
that is that is something that we've
announced in the past several months and
as you saw at the nalls the null Summit
that just occurred recently in Mexico
City that coordination will continue
during their bilat President Biden with
prime minister Trudeau also committed
continue coordination with Partners on
the U.S Security Council on the next
steps to support stability to Haiti
including support to the National to
Haitian National Police and so that is a
commitment that the president has and we
will continue again to coordinate to see
what we can do with no new forces
underground at the moment too they don't
have anything to uh to announce or
preview at this time
I have Kevin is uh what's happening in
the Middle East in Israel and the
Palestinian territories we saw what
happened in Jennings yesterday we were
hearing that the five people were killed
in the synagogue in Jerusalem today I
know that the secretaries did Lincoln's
going is in the area there's a
commitment to the two-state solution
that's going to be reaffirmed but is the
president does the president intend to
do anything concrete towards the
solution uh this year for us so as you
know we're aware of the reports
yesterday you just mentioned secretary
blinken's travel so we look we recognize
the very real security challenges facing
Israel and the Palestinian Authority
that is something that we recognize and
condemn terrorist groups planning and
carrying out attacks against innocent
civilians and that is something that you
will continue to hear from us and we
will be consistent on that we also
regret the loss of innocent lives and
injury and injuries to civilians and are
deeply concerned by the escalating cycle
of violence in the West Bank over the
past few days our Administration has
been closely engaged with the Israeli
and Palestinian Authority on the recent
violence and to urge de-escalation
we underscore the urgent need for all
parties to de-escalate to prevent
further loss of civilian life and work
together to improve the security
situation in the West Bank Palestinians
and Israelis equally deserve to live
safely and securely securely securely
and you'll hear that from clearly
secretary blinken as you just mentioned
his commitment that the president has to
a two-state solution and we will
continue to call on de-escalation
can I have Jessica follow-up to that I
know during May of 2021 when there was
violence in the region President Biden
got on the phone with Netanyahu he was
more are personally engaged is there a
reason why we're not seeing the
president himself hop on the phone and
be more directly engaged well as you
know the president is very committed uh
to um the security uh the real security
challenges that they're facing here uh
in Israeli and in Palestine Authority
and we're going to continue to condemn
certainly the terrorist groups planning
and we'll continue to be vocal don't
have anything to read out as far as the
president calling the Prime Minister but
as you know as was just mentioned uh
secretary blinken is in the region
we had National Security adviser Jake
Sullivan who was there just last week
and I think that shows our commitment
to the region and so we'll continue to
see that I just don't have anything
specific on the president uh the
president's involvement good thanks
Karen um the people in the hill are
talking about a debt limit extension
until September would the White House
support um
look we've been very clear that the debt
limit should be dealt with without
conditions we've been very very clear on
that and we'll continue to make that
clear and and we believe that Congress
should act in a bipartisan way as they
did three times in the last
Administration as they did 78 times
since 1960 49 times with a Republican
president and 29 times with a Democratic
president this is incredibly important
we have seen reports that if a default
happens six million jobs could be lost
right we're talking about an economy
that we saw the GDP just the other day
2.9 percent growth which is better than
was expected so we're seeing a growing
economy we're seeing record unemployment
50-year low we're seeing almost 11 jobs
created under this president what we
should be doing and what Congress should
be working with us on is how do we
continue to build on that success not do
political stunts and so we'll continue
to be clear on that it should be done
without political stance it should be
done in a bipartisan way as it has done
has been done many times before
this could be a vote next month on a
nationwide Tick Tock ban the zoy house
still have security certain concerns
about the ad then you'd have a different
stance on look our positions have not
has not changed on on Tick Tock I'm not
going to get into uh into any specifics
as you know it's under review by the
committee so we're just not going to get
into details on that okay
thanks Frank uh David archrada former
Tech staffer for President Obama uh
President Obama wrote in a piece today
for the Atlantic that brought it in the
White House seemingly have violated
every precept speed transparency
Contrition of Crisis Communications in
relation to the way that you have
communicated about the classified
documents found in his possession I'm
wondering uh if you agree with that
assessment and
well look I know David axroth very well
I was part of his I was I was part of
his program that he had at the
University of Chicago and I respect him
uh wholeheartedly and got to work with
him during the Obama Biden Obama bite
Administration he has his opinion I'm
not going to make judgments on that and
and he's allowed to uh to to share what
he thinks but I will say this uh and um
and I'm going to be very careful and
prudent here and we take we take
classified information and classify
documents very seriously and the
president's team is fully cooperating
with the current legal process at this
time I'm just not going to say anything
more this is not a question about the
handling of classified documents it's a
question of communication I just I just
answered your question I just answered
your question I literally just answered
your question but I did I did whether or
not you think the White House has done a
good job no but I answered the first
part I answered it in my first part
which is I know David Axelrod he has
every right to have his opinion and I've
known him for a long time I've worked
closely with him and that's all I'm
going to say okay Karen is there a
specific reason the president's leaving
Camp David to go to Delaware just for
that one night I don't have anything to
preview about what he's going to be
doing specifically or I can tell you is
that he's going to be leaving a Camp
David and going to Wilmington Delaware
and his travel for next week the
Baltimore New York travel obviously is
infrastructure related and tunnel
specific Philadelphia on the economy but
they're obviously very blue cities why
the focus on those three places next
week why did you guys pick that well I
think you know I think well first I'm
not going to get ahead of the president
who will lay out the importance of his
travels to those particular tunnel and
why he wanted to highlight those tunnels
so certainly not going to get ahead of
him look the bipartisan remember it's a
bipartisan infrastructure legislation we
were in Kentucky in the beginning of the
year which was a bridge in Kentucky that
that was really important in the region
and we had you saw Mitch McConnell you
know you saw a bipartisan effort of
folks who have elected officials who
came together to talk about a bridge
that for for decades Presidents had
wanted to fix and have not been able to
so we were in Kentucky not too long ago
this next week you'll see the president
in Maryland and in uh and in New York so
I think those are important right when
you think about what the president has
said for the past several years is he is
a president for everyone and you see
that in his pieces of legislation
because they will benefit people in New
York they will benefit people in New
Jersey they will benefit people in
Kentucky and Ohio just across the
country red States blue States rural
areas urban areas and I think that's
what you're seeing that's what you're
going to see next week from from the
president as he trial he continues to
travel and lay out what what historic
pieces of legislation like the
bipartisan infrastructure legislation is
going to do you for the for the American
people I should say not legislation but
law you'll be doing travel right up to
the state of the union with a similar
message I don't want to get ahead of of
his schedule uh but clearly he sees the
State of the Union as an important
opportunity to speak directly to the
American people about how he sees uh the
uh the future of this country as the
President says you've heard him say many
times he's an optimist and he said that
just yesterday and he wants to continue
to talk about the economy where we are
and where he thinks we need to do to go
especially as if we can work together in
a bipartisan way to continue to deliver
for the American people
thank you so much
um so is the president going to go to
Europe the next month to Mark the
one-year anniversary of the invasion of
Ukraine and I understand if you're not
going to come in on concrete travel
plans but going to Ukraine is this an
option for the president today I'm not
going to get into uh the president's uh
travel from here and I can say that we
currently and you guys heard us say this
already in the last 24 hours we
currently don't have any travel plans
for the anniversary what I can tell you
uh is um and what I meant to say at the
beginning is I don't want to you're
asking me about the security going to
Ukraine I just I it is not it is not
appropriate for me to talk about the
president's uh uh any type of security
from here but what I can say is that
planning for how we will recognize the
one-year anniversary is well underway
here at the White House and across the
government but as a general matter I'm
just not going to uh going to get into
internal discussions or read out any
options that we're currently looking at
and once we have something if we have
something to to certainly share we will
but right now we currently have no plans
to travel for the anniversary
uh did Elon Musk request to meet with
the president himself while he was in
town this week well what I can tell you
I would I would refer you to Elon Musk I
don't have any requests to share with
you right now what I can tell you is
that he did not meet with the president
it was his two advisors senior advisors
as I just laid out John podesta and
Mitch Lander who met with Elon Musk
today I just don't have anything else to
share about who about who asked who I'm
following up somewhat related to EVS but
gas prices
um it could hit four dollars in the next
couple of months the national average
according to a lot of the experts like
Gas Buddy uh How likely is it that the
president Taps into the Strategic
petroleum Reserve again this year to try
to lower prices so I
um secretary granholm as you know was
here I believe on Monday and she was
asked this question and so that is
certainly something that's under her
purview as as well if we don't have
anything to share on that what I can say
about gas prices more more broadly is
that while some temporary Refinery
outages and maintenance are impacting
gas prices right now the price of gas is
still down about 1.50 cents since June
Peak and around where it was when Putin
invaded Ukraine the department of energy
is working with refineries to bring
capacity back online swiftly and safely
and the president will continue to do
everything he can to keep lowering costs
for the American families so look in
contrast to what the white the House
Republicans want to do we have that spro
bill that they put forward in trying to
you know stop the president for doing
everything that he can to lower costs
and so we're doing the opposite we're
going to continue to do the work to make
sure that we tackle inflation one of the
most important economic priorities of
this President and uh and so we'll
continue to do that work any any
additional
um you know tapping of the spray Pro I
just don't have anything for you at this
time refilling it especially now that
oil prices are climbing again could get
up to 110 a barrel when do you see the
timeline for refilling it so I we had
laid out the plan of how that was going
to work I don't have anything updated on
that I would refer you to the Department
of energy for any specifics to that
thank you entirely uh the
previous police brutality cases in the
past couple years the officers have been
white that's not the case
in this in this case is the president
concerned that within the culture of
policing there is a comfort with
violence and an entitlement to use
violence that would lead these officers
to beat a man to death for for fleeing
from them during a traffic stop does he
feel that police
may feel emboldened to do these things
and what would he do about that to do so
so look I mean the president has called
for a meaningful reform he's called on
it uh very clearly and has spoken to it
the last two years and he wants to see
real change he wants to make sure there
is accountability with law enforcement
officers who violate their oats and he
also said that we need to build that
long lasting relationship between
enforcement and the vast majority we
understand and he believes of whom we're
we're the badge honorably and that is
important too and and those communities
not only they wear it honorably but they
also to serve the community to serve
into the community that they want to
protect and so look we're we're not
going to get into psych you know do any
any psychology here and going into the
the minds of
of uh of folks but what we can say is we
believe that we there needs to be
meaningful reform which is why the
president acted and took executive
action when uh when Congress could not I
would just follow up on that his
predecessor in 2017 uh encouraged uh
police officers to don't be too nice and
suggested that they might uh hit the
heads of prisoners on the tops of their
patrol cars
does the president
have any plans to speak to police
officers and say that this is kind of
behavior is not acceptable does he plan
to address any police groups or anything
like that I understand the question
Andrew but I think the president has
been very clear he's been very clear on
the importance of having true reform of
the important of making sure that
communities feel safe he took action
right he took executive action to deal
with that specific specific issue
and and that's what he's going to
continue to do he's going to you know
use the tools that he can by by taking
executive action and call on Congress to
truly make meaningful reform that's
going to deal with an issue that is
devastating you know disproportionately
unfortunately black and brown
communities
so when you talk about infrastructure
you say it's important for the president
to have a chance to speak directly to
the American people why doesn't he want
to speak directly to the American people
now that some big cities are racing
potentially this weekend for riots
so he put out a statement yesterday
and I think when a statement comes from
the president of the United States it
has a powerful impact and he was very
clear in that statement he offered his
condolences to the family of Tyree
Nichols he also joined the family in
calling for peaceful protests that is an
important statement that the president
could make and you have me here
reiterating what the president has said
and we're going to continue to do that
it's not the first time I've laid out
the Dobbs decision was it was a time
where we were calling for peaceful
protest and there's been other times
even before then so and and let's not
forget election day where we did the
same so I think the president's words
really matter they have weight and it's
important that we the American people
heard from him directly okay on the
documents have any more classified
documents been located in any places
associated with President Biden I would
refer you to the White House council's
Office okay and why do White House
officials insist that the president
self-reported the classified materials
if his lawyers initially called the
White House and not the justice
department I would refer you to the
White House Council but we heard from
this Podium the other day that President
Biden uh self-reported the materials
that's not what exactly what happened
who did you hear that from John Kirby
well I would refer you to the White
House Council
follow up West Bank is the
administration concerned that the
current Israeli government which many
observers have characterized as the most
right-wing in the country's history is
escalating the violence in the West Bank
prime minister Nani Yahoo has often said
that he is in control of the Coalition
does the administration still have faith
in his ability to do that so look we
have been very clear on looking forward
to working with um
uh than the Prime Minister as you know
the president has a relationship uh with
the Prime Minister
um certainly not going to go into uh
specifics from here of what you laid out
you know that uh secretary blinken is
currently in the region and so was uh so
was National Security adviser Jake
Sullivan and I'm just going to leave it
there I'm not going to go into
diplomatic conversations from here I'm
not going to go into anything more
specific than that but again we're going
to you know continue to continue that
relationship that we've had
briefly we just heard that there are at
least seven people who have been killed
in an attack on a synagogue in Jerusalem
I don't know if you've heard that or not
do you have any comments no I have not
heard of that but but clearly we have
been asking uh both sides to de-escalate
and we'll continue to do that but I it's
hard to speak on something that I have
not read about
the question can we uh get a reaction on
the
to re-evaluate his Asylum restrictions
please look if you look at what the
president put forward uh in most
recently as it relates to the border
security and the border security
measures it's actually working and we
see that with the parolee program more
specifically and I think it's it's
important that the president is using
the tools that he has in front of him to
deal with a real issue and so the number
of people crossing on unlawfully from
Cuba Haiti Nicaragua Venezuela declined
by 89 in less than three weeks 89 and
this month we're on track to see the
lowest levels of monthly border
encounters since February 2021 our
measures again are working because we
are treating this matter with urgency
we're not using it as a political stunt
we're not using it as a political
football we're taking this very
seriously but as you just mentioned some
states are trying to block or our
success and measures because they would
rather use immigration as a political
stunt and and for their campaign or you
know instead of trying to solve it so
again we're going to do the work the
prison is going to do the work on behalf
of the American people and deal with a
real issue not just here but that has
been affecting a global essentially a
global phenomenon that we have seen this
past year or two so again his measures
his measures are the measures that he
just put in are working and uh and we're
gonna continue to focus on that follow
up okay well Tommy Nichols um you you
mentioned that President Biden has
called for Congress to pass the George
floydville or from Black Americans who
are deeply Disturbed and frustrated by
this continuous these cases of police
brutality who voted for President Biden
in 2020 because of what happened to
George Floyd
what would be the practice message to
Black Americans who are feeling like the
president is not taking a more
aggressive tone when speaking to
Congress to pass this bill before look I
think and I said a little bit of this
moments ago we understand the outrage
that that the community has as we have
said it is disproportionately when you
see this type of violence is
disproportionately affecting black and
brown communities but I think if you
look at the president's actions and what
he has been able to do and using the
tools that he has when Congress could
not get this done they could not move
forward with the George Floyd policing
act he took action he took executive
actions and was used the tools in front
of him to move the conversation forward
to move the ball forward on dealing with
an issue that is devastating devastating
communities now he's going to continue
to continue to do what he's been doing
is to ask Congress to act and I I also
think I would refer you back to his
comments his speeches he's made speeches
on this on what how this is affecting
communities how important it is to come
together to deal with the real issue
he's talked about this over the last two
years again you know I I would look at
his actions look at what he's been able
to do and I think that's important too
thank you Karine um on the Elon Musk
meeting did his Twitter ownership come
up at all no
the topic of Hunter Biden's laptop
I would I would refer you to uh two
Hunters Representatives on that thanks
to the back here good Brian I want to go
back to November 2nd
um why didn't the president go public on
November 2nd when he found out from his
lawyers at classified documents were
found I would refer you to the White
House Council who is who has who has put
out a a
statements on this on their timeline and
talking speaking to this my colleagues
from the White House Council has had
conversations with many of you answering
questions on this I would refer you to
the White House Council federal
investigation you could have gone public
I would refer to my wife the White House
go ahead Alex go ahead Alex I mean I
spoke with the New York city mayor Eric
Adams this afternoon and he's just very
concerned as he said in media
appearances in recent days that the
White House is not doing enough
uh to prepare for a new uh surge of
migrants many of whom are going to end
up in cities like Chicago New York here
in DC
um and as you know it's not just
DeSantis and Abbott uh sending buses of
migrants to these cities it's Jared
Polis a Democrat um in Colorado as well
to
what do you have to say to those
concerns from mayor Adams look here's
what I would say and I said it I
answered this question
um with one of your colleagues which is
we believe and we have seen the numbers
and the data that the board enforcement
measures have dramatically reduced the
number of people attempting to enter the
country unlawfully and I just mentioned
the parolee program that was extended to
Cuba and Nicaragua and Haiti and how
we've seen those numbers come down by 89
percent and so that's because of the
measures that the president has put
forth and so look we're going to
continue to do the work I just mentioned
as well we're going to see the lowest
we're on track to see the lowest levels
of monthly border encounters since
February 2021. why is that is because of
the work that this president has done to
using the tools using what he's able to
do from the federal from the federal
government from where he sits look
you know when the president walked in
the very first piece of legislation that
he put forth was an Immigration Reform
Bill that's how seriously he took this
that's how important it was for him to
secure the border and deal with and and
uh illegal migration and what he has
asked for is to have Congress act and I
know you mentioned uh uh a couple of
Democrats but the vast majority of folks
who have been pushing back against this
have been Republicans we've seen very
very in a stark way of the political
stunts that they have taken so look he's
willing to work on this he has said this
many times he's willing to work in a
bipartisan way to get this done but in
the meantime he's going to take actions
as we've seen and those actions are
actually working and so that's what I
that's how I would answer your question
on the hill we are yes we are encouraged
by those conversations this is what
we've been asking right we've been
asking for Congress to uh to take action
to really take this in a serious way and
so we welcome that we welcome
conversations that are currently
happening on dealing with immigration
reform in a real way okay Courtney okay
I wanted to ask about the juvenile
releases that the Supreme Court is going
to consider next month say that one more
time it's okay I'll be louder the
student debt cases that the Supreme
Court is going to consider now so I
still did hear you the first part oh
students
it's me it's not you
um the student debt cases one of the
questions that's at issue in both of the
cases is whether the president went
beyond his authority in pardoning all of
that debt can you talk about more of
what these cases mean for your broader
agenda there's been a lot of different
executive actions that the president has
taken that have been questioned by the
Supreme Court
outside of the context of students at
which I know is something you all really
care about but thinking about how these
cases could impact going forward how the
president uses his own authority on
other issues so look I you know I'll say
also speak to this more broadly
um and look we're confident in our
illegal authority to carry carry out
this program as it relates specifically
to the student debt and you know we're
looking for we're looking for a plan uh
the president this was a plan that the
president put forward to move things
forward right to continue to help
Americans who need a little bit of a
breathing room as you hear the president
speak to if you think about the 2000 of
relief that it that it's going to give
to those who need it the most if you
think about the nearly 90 percent of
benefits will go to out of out of school
borrows making less than seventy five
thousand dollars a year and so this is
what the president is trying to do he's
been doing this with his economic
policies that you've seen the last two
years continuing to make sure that we
help those who are truly in need and
building if you think of if you think
about what the economic uh theory has
been for the past decades right which
has trickle-down economics the president
is changing that and saying no we do not
need trickle-down economics he is saying
that we need to build an economy from
the bottom up middle out and if you
think about his plan it is working it is
indeed working and he always is going to
take steps and use his bully pulpit to
uh to make sure that Americans have an
opportunity to really uh to really not
be left behind that is so important so
that they can you think about the
Student Loan program it'll give
Americans who can buy a car can start a
family can buy a home and really bring
put back into the economy because they
have a little bit of extra more cash and
I think that is how we should see this
that is how we should see how the
president wants to deliver for the
American people and uh he's gonna it's
not going to stop them it's not going to
stop him to continue to do that thanks
everybody